Whoo‐hoo!
Narrator: We celebrate
the risk‐takers...
Why not quit the job
and go for it?
...the idea‐makers...
We can really change
the world together.
[ Screams ]
Narrator: ...the ones who
determine their own fate.
‐Whoo!
‐We got a deal!
Narrator:
We celebrate entrepreneurs.
I want y'all to think ‐‐
Who's next?
Narrator:
This is "Shark Tank."
And tonight founder of the
category‐defining company Spanx,
Sara Blakely joins the Tank.
Let's make "Boobie"
a household name.
Well, hold on there,
cowboy.
Now you're speaking
their language, right?
‐Come on!
‐Aww!
‐What is that?
‐[ Laughs ]
That is so sick.
Do you have any proof
that they work?
Anecdotal, for sure.
You're asking us
to invest money in you.
I've done it all myself.
I don't understand what
that has to do with the patent.
Listen, you have to be willing
to point out
the difference
on why you're better.
Well, I don't want
to be negative.
It's not about going negative,
it's about being factual.
‐Sorry to disappoint you.
‐What?
I can't even see us
having a conversation.
Oh, no! [ Laughs ]
♪♪
Narrator: First into the Tank
is a company
that makes it easy
to start your own business.
♪♪
Hi, I'm Alice Rossiter,
and I'm from
Boston, Massachusetts.
I'm the founder and CEO
of Alice's Table,
and my company
is seeking $250,000
for 6.25% equity.
Whoa.
Alice's Table empowers women
across the country
to launch
their own businesses,
teaching
flower‐arranging classes.
There are brilliant moms
everywhere
looking for flexible
and creative ways to make money
and lead in their communities,
and millions of millennials
searching for side hustles.
So I can't wait to show you
what one of the classes is like.
So, Sara, will you join me
up here
for a flower‐arranging
demonstration?
Sure.
Absolutely.
Come on up.
Each of you in front of you
have an apron and a full set up,
so feel free
to put your apron on.
‐[ Laughs ]
‐You, too.
Okay.
All right.
[ Laughs ]
This is what
they call an apron?
That's an apron, yeah.
[ Laughs ]
So, I've gone ahead
and greened your base,
which is the first set up.
‐Okay.
‐You also have cocktails
in front of you
because flowers
are always better
with a little bit of cocktail.
What are we drinking?
You're drinking
a Moscow Mule.
[ Laughter ]
Ooh!
'Cause why not?
So, 9:00 in the morning
while you're trimming
the flowers,
you're pounding back
the vodka.
Exactly!
We just keep it fun.
I got it.
So, the first step ‐‐
we're gonna take
our hydrangeas,
grab both of them,
take your clippers,
and just give 'em
a cut at 45‐degree angle...
Okay.
...and put 'em
into your arrangement.
Okay.
Yep, and now put them
into your vase.
Uh, into the vase
with greenery right there.
‐This one?
‐Yep.
Greiner: [ Laughs ] You would
think we've never seen a flower.
Could I take the thorns off Lori
with this?
No.
Could I take the thorns off him?
Rossiter: Go ahead and put five
of your roses into your vases.
‐Okay.
‐Also, you can blow on the roses
and blow them open
a little bit more.
Warm air
does open them up.
‐Lori.
‐Uh, yes, Kevin?
Blow on this.
[ Laughter ]
So, now if you want
to finish off
with your gerber daisies
and your calla lilies,
and some hypericum berry
if you would like to.
This is very therapeutic.
It's fun.
‐Very nice.
‐That looks good, Mark.
Rossiter: Looking good
over there.
I got skills.
Awesome!
[ Laughs ]
So, if you want to take it
back to your seat.
All right. Perfect.
All I keep thinking is, uh,
that valuation
better be as beautiful
as this.
‐So, Alice...
‐Yes.
...what is this business
that you are presenting to us?
So, we built a platform
where we help women
launch their businesses.
So they buy into the system,
and they buy in at $699,
and they get a kit
of materials.
So they get basically everything
you see here,
which is aprons, clippers,
rose strippers, buckets ‐‐
all of that stuff.
And what's your cost
to put that together?
Our cost on that
is about $550.
Oh, wow. $550.
Just so I understand ‐‐
They come to you,
they're doing it
at their home,
at a party space,
wherever they want to ‐‐
Wherever they want. Yep.
But do they get
the flowers?
So, they get the flowers
per event.
So really what they're getting
with that is the box of stuff,
and then
they're getting training,
and it's developed
that way
because the vision
for the business
is that if we can build
a business in a box,
flowers is just one
of those iterations,
and then from there
it switches
to be
an event‐management platform.
So, I just wrote you
a check for $699.
Yep.
What's my expectation?
You get a box of materials,
you get training,
and then you're launching
your classes.
So you're going out
and looking for venues,
you're looking for, um,
ways to sell tickets.
So you're gonna sell me
on starting another business
selling our experience
on cutting flowers and drinking.
Exactly.
Got it. But why flowers?
I started with flowers
because they can be done
anywhere, right?
So I could take
this arrangement class
to a bar‐restaurant,
I could take it
to someone's home,
to country club ‐‐
Okay, th‐‐
that makes sense.
And many people have bought
Alice's Table so far?
So, we have 53 Execs
right now.
"53 Execs" ‐‐
That's what you call 'em.
Execs, yeah.
53 people have paid you
the $699?
Yes.
Do you make revenue
per tickets sold?
Yes.
So we take a 30% commission...
30%. Okay.
...on all tickets sold,
and tickets are $65.
Let me sum this up
from a consumer standpoint.
Yeah.
I always loved ‐‐
It's so important
to think like a consumer.
So, if I'm the consumer,
what I'm getting
is a flower arrangement
for $65...
Yep.
...and a good time.
And a good time ‐‐
that's what you get.
And I met other women
who are like‐minded.
Yep. And now ‐‐
And if I were to order
my own arrangement,
it's about $65 plus?
Exactly.
‐Okay.
‐I was actually Exec number one.
I did this for eight months
to try and see how it worked
and wanted to do it myself,
and actually I sold
over $100,000 of tickets.
‐In what period of time?
It was about eight months.
In eight months.
That's good.
Wow.
You did a ‐‐ I'm ‐‐
And I'm just...
Yeah.
...blown away by that ‐‐
you went around
selling tickets...
I did. Yes.
...to flower arranging,
and you made $100,000.
Now, has anybody else
emulated that?
We have one Exec that's doing
about 110 tickets a month,
so she's getting close.
John: Is there an average
of how much
an Exec can do
in a month?
The average right now ‐‐
They're doing
17‐and‐a‐half tickets a month.
Um...
And you're getting $30
from every ticket.
Yes. No, sorry. $19.
Blakely: So, Alice, I see
a hole in this
that I want to talk to you
about.
So, you're selling
tickets ‐‐
they're coming to learn
how to arrange flowers.
Yep.
You don't have something next
to sell them, right?
Yep.
So once you've trained
these people
how to arrange flowers...
Yep.
...what do you ‐‐
You have to keep on
finding new people ‐‐
You got to keep finding ‐‐
It's ‐‐ it's
a really intense model
of having to always
find new people.
Right. Well, they do come back
multiple times, right?
So, we've seen
about 20% repeat.
Alice,
what are your sales?
Um, about $600,000.
Not your total.
Sorry. Our total ‐‐
So, 30% of that.
‐You make 30% ‐‐
‐Your net revenue will be...
‐Yeah.
‐...$180,000.
Yes.
So, let's make it $150,000
after tax.
Okay.
$250,000 for 6.25% ‐‐
back of the envelope,
$4 million valuation.
You want me to pay 30 times
this year's profit
for a nonproprietary
flower‐arranging club.
"Nonproprietary
flower‐arranging club."
He already knows
the answer
before he asked the question.
‐I don't ‐‐
You really think this thing
is worth 4 million bucks?
We're gonna find out.
Look, I like it,
but the valuation's insane.
Alice, I have a lot of companies
over eight years...
‐Yeah.
‐...on "Shark Tank,"
and the truth is
that the majority of my returns
have come from ones
run by women,
so I love investing in strong,
smart, go‐get‐'em women.
You're one of those.
I hate your valuation,
I love your business, okay?
I'll give you the $250,000
for 25%,
which gives you
a "millski" valuation.
A whole millski!
A millski's
a good value for it.
‐All right, you got an offer.
‐Alice, everyone's gonna
have issue
with your valuation,
so can you take a moment
and justify it yourself?
Yeah, it's about
the top line revenue
is where we valued it
at 7x from that,
and then also I don't view this
as a flower company.
No, it's not.
I view it as a platform
with which we deliver
a business in a box,
and we can deliver
any business in a box ‐‐
Right, so that's the key.
Right?
And that's ‐‐
So, this is just your first,
um, proof of concept,
right, selling flowers?
Exactly.
You can go
in a hundred different ways.
You just want to plug in
as many businesses
to enable entrepreneurs.
Yep.
That's what this is about,
right?
‐Totally. 100%.
‐And how many different lines?
I can't say I have, like,
a five ‐‐
you know, a five‐product
line projection for that.
That's okay. You're gonna get
your ideas from your customers.
John: Alice,
we're going in a ‐‐
into a time
when entrepreneurs
can do things like this
from home...
Yeah.
...and you can empower them,
and you want
to empower women,
so I love
that aspect of it.
But I also think
that there's a bad message
I would be sending to give you
a $4 million valuation
on what everyday Americans
are doing every two minutes.
Oh, come on, Daymond.
So I'm out.
Okay.
Let me ‐‐ Let me try
to help him.
Can I ‐‐ Wait, can I get
one thing clear about the ‐‐
She's doing
the exact opposite.
She's saying anybody
could start a business for $700,
is what she's saying.
Yes.
One second ‐‐
I love that
"Take control of your life,
start it right now.
Don't depend on anybody else.
$700." Great.
But the valuation
to give her that
with the proof of concept
that she has right now ‐‐
to me, it's too much.
Okay.
Alice,
who else could do $100,000
of flower‐arranging
tickets?
I think that ‐‐
I mean, I'm gonna give you
a huge compliment.
‐Lots, lots of women.
‐That's extraordinary.
I think that there
are millions and millions
of women out there
that can do that.
Lots of ‐‐ yeah.
Okay, Alice,
uh, let's get to ‐‐
Alice, have you ever
heard of Wine ‐‐
You ever heard
of Wine and Design?
‐I have.
‐That's a "Shark Tank" company.
Yes.
Instead of flowers,
it's wine and painting.
Join the O'Leary family
of strong executive women.
Mark,
what are you gonna do?
Forget about
any other offer.
I'm waiting for him
to shut up. Um...
Are you gonna make an offer,
or are you gonna pontificate?
Let's hear the offer.
[ Chuckles ]
Um, I love what you're doing.
I like the idea that you want
to go into multiple lines.
I don't like the idea
it's only 6.25%.
♪♪
Narrator: One Shark is out.
Alice has one offer on the table
from Kevin
for her business‐in‐a‐box
platform, Alice's Table.
Mark is also interested,
but he doesn't like the amount
of equity that she's offering.
What I'd like to do
is offer 250K
for 10% plus the option
to buy more in your next round.
At the same valuation.
Whatever
that current valuation is.
Whatever ‐‐ Okay.
But I'm gonna ask Sara
to come in for part of it.
Do you agree ‐‐
working it that way?
Yes. I'll do that deal.
Because if you have somebody
who's walked the walk
and talked the talk,
it's gonna
accelerate things.
Yep.
The value
escalates dramatically.
So I want the option...
Yep.
...to raise an additional 10%
for Sara and I.
So if you raise it $8 million,
we'll pay the $8 million.
‐Okay.
‐If you raise it $10 million,
we'll pay the $10 million
so that when
we help you increase the value,
you benefit,
we benefit.
Yep.
In order for this to be
a $100 million company...
‐Yes.
‐...which I think it can be...
I agree.
...then you're gonna
have to raise more money,
because we want to go
nationally, global.
So to help get you started,
you're gonna have two really,
really good entrepreneurs,
great entrepreneurs...
‐Yep.
...here to help you
brand and market it.
So you get
the best of both worlds...
Right. Yep.
...we get the value,
so all you have to do
is say "Yes."
Or you get Mr. Wonderful.
So, we're in this together?
We're in this together.
What do you say? You got
to give me an answer right now.
‐Yes.
‐Wait a sec‐‐
‐Ohh!
‐[ Laughs ]
‐I'm jumping on it.
‐Wow.
‐Congratulations.
‐Got to give her a rose!
Exactly.
That's awesome.
I'm so excited.
We're gonna help
so many entrepreneurs together.
I can't wait.
I'm so excited.
‐Yes. Wonderful.
‐Thank you.
Thank you.
Congratulations.
Thank you. Oh! Thank you!
Two roses!
‐Bye!
‐Thank you.
‐Alice!
‐Congrats, Alice.
Alice,
it's over between us.
Oh, no!
[ Laughter ]
Bye! Thank you!
Awesome.
I'm so excited
to have both Sara and Mark.
They were both the people
that I was hoping to work with,
and to have both of them
on my team
and helping me to help
future entrepreneurs
is just phenomenal.
What Alice has done is create
a program
that allows her
to go out there and say,
"For $700, if you're willing
to put in the work"...
Yep.
..."you can make
some money."
Why do you give her
such a high valuation?
When I said
this can be $100 million,
I wanted to see if she's ‐‐
like, she was taken aback.
She wasn't.
I would've preferred
you stayed out of it, Mark.
Greiner: It was a good deal.
[ Laughter ]
Congratulations.
That's always the case
with Kevin.
♪♪
Narrator: In season 6,
we watched Rob, Avin,
and Jonathan
make a deal with Daymond John
for their portable safe,
the AquaVault.
Let's see
what they're up to now.
Samtani: Before "Shark Tank,"
we were just selling
our project online
and all over Miami Beach.
Since Daymond's come on board,
he's helped us get
into that retail area
which we've lacked the most.
AquaVaults can now be found
at Bed Bath & Beyond,
theme parks,
and cruise ships,
and virtually every water park
in the country.
We just launched our
newest product, the FlexSafe,
the soft/resistant
portable safe.
Would you two be interested
in renting an AquaVault today?
Now every beachfront hotel
in Miami Beach
rents AquaVaults
to their guests.
You put the code, you put it
on a chair, you're good to go.
Awesome.
Thank you.
When we pitched on "Shark Tank,"
we did $87,000 in sales.
Two‐and‐a‐half years later,
we're now at $7 million
in sales.
Mr. Morales.
Hey, how are ya?
John: The guys have invited me
to join them
at a meeting
at City Hall today
to talk about how the product
has been performing
on the beach and helping
to keep the beach safe.
Your product's been out there
since 2015,
and over that 2‐year period,
we've seen a real decrease
in the number of, uh,
thefts out on the beach.
Because of that,
we will be putting signs
up and down our seven miles
of beautiful beach
letting our visitors
and residents know
"Keep your stuff safe,"
uh, "and go use AquaVault."
Kinas: Beyond the
business aspect and the sales,
what really gets us moving
is that we're providing
a peace of mind
that never existed.
Now guests can actually
enjoy vacations
in a way
they never had before.
John: The future for AquaVault
is to replicate this magic
all around the world.
It's not just about money
and a product ‐‐
they're helping keep
the beaches safe.
I'm really proud of the guys.
This is way more than business,
and I couldn't be more honored
to be a part of it.
♪♪
Narrator: Next up is what the
entrepreneurs believe
is a better way...
Whoo‐hoo! Yeah!
Narrator: ...for everyone
to enjoy a favorite water sport.
‐Whoo‐hoo!
‐[ Laughs ]
What's up, Sharks?
My name is Glen Duff.
I'm Nick Kierpiec.
And I'm Scott Parks.
We're from
Williamsburg, Virginia,
and our company is ZUP.
ZUP!
We're seeking
a $300,000 investment
in exchange for
a 10% equity stake
in our business.
Everybody loves a day
out on the water,
but water skiing
and wakeboarding
can be a little intimidating
to learn.
With ZUP boards,
you can ride with confidence,
whether it's your first time
or your 40th time.
With our new innovation,
we'll have you ZUP
and smiling
first pull, every pull.
If you look at the video,
each board is deigned
to meet your level of comfort
with two foot straps,
two side handles,
and a double ZUP tow rope.
So you can start off lying down
like on a boogie board,
easily pull yourself up
to a knee board position,
then, when you're ready,
you can stand up.
If Grandpa can do it,
everybody can do it.
[ Chuckles ]
So, this is
the easiest board
you'll ever tow
behind your boat,
Jet Ski, pontoon,
whatever.
So you just start
by laying on it.
It's easy.
It's stable,
and you can climb all over it.
Get on your knees,
go like this,
cross the wake,
the handle stays on magically ‐‐
then if you're ready,
you want to go
to the next position,
pull the handle
towards you.
Now we can stand up
to water skiing on one board.
Now I'm gonna drop
the handle down.
What just happened?
My fingers did not get anywhere
near a pinch point.
I have four daughters,
and I always freaked out
when they were about
to put the handle back,
thinking "Don't pinch
your fingers!"
So we created this,
patented it ‐‐
this is super safe.
So now I'm tired.
I'm gonna take a break.
We really do this
all the time.
[ Laughs ]
So, guys, that's ZUP,
and at this time,
we'd love
to take your questions.
What are your sales?
Kierpiec: So, since we started
our business,
in four years, we've done
$2.5 million in sales.
How 'bout this year?
This year we have
a sales goal of $1 million.
We're actually on track
to do better than that.
Greiner: And where are you
selling?
So, we sell all across
the country.
We have 180 retailers
in the Untied States.
We also have retailers
in Canada, the U. K.,
Japan, Australia.
Do you sell online?
We do sell online.
We sell direct to consumer
through our website
and through other channels.
And who's your biggest
direct‐to‐consumer outlet?
Is it your website
or Amazon or ‐‐
It would definitely be
Amazon.
‐Amazon. Yeah.
‐Amazon?
Well, how much
do you sell it for?
Our highest‐price board is
the one you see in the middle,
and that's the DoMore Board.
That's priced at $429.
And our best‐selling board
is the YouGotThis Board,
and that's priced at $279.
And then our lowest‐priced
is the YouGo Board,
and that's priced at $219.
And what does it cost you
to make 'em?
Our average margin
across all products is 54%.
So, guys,
I am really interested
in the product
differentiation ‐‐
why you're different
and unique
in comparison
to the competition.
Right. So, I understand
your background,
and being
an industry disrupter yourself,
we ended up doing that
in this industry accidentally.
We were ignorant of the fact
that we couldn't do it,
and we ended up doing it.
As a designer for 30 years,
I'm constantly
innovating ideas.
And basically,
I have four daughters,
[Voice breaking]
and my wife said, you know,
[Normal voice] "Our kids
are getting a little older,
and they're not gonna
want to hang out with us
when they're teenagers.
We need to get a boat."
[ Laughter ]
She goes, "Yeah!
Boats are magnets.
They'll bring their friends,
they'll hang out with us,
and every day
we're having a blast.
Tell us
about your patent.
We have three current utility
patents that are granted.
Three, and ‐‐
They're granted.
Yes.
Tell me about them.
Basically, we have
a system of riding
that builds confidence
in the kids.
As you see, everybody
on the boat is gonna be happy,
but the way
it builds confidence
is you're not having
to be pulled up out of the water
and squirreling around until
you figure out how to do it.
So, it might take 15 times
to pull somebody up.
Boat drivers are awesome.
They have such a heart
to teach somebody.
Wait. You know what?
I'm confused.
Okay. I'm ‐‐
I'm sorry. Respectfully...
‐It's all right.
‐Sure.
I don't understand what that
has to do with the patent.
Lori and I are basically
asking the same question.
‐Yes. Okay.
‐Tell us the specific things
on your board
that are unique to you
that does not exist
on other boards.
So, the foot straps
are actually patented.
What those do is they're
actually multi‐use foot straps.
We use them as elbow pads,
we use them as knee pads,
and we use them
as foot straps.
Well, there are foot pads
on wakeboards.
‐Right.
‐Yes, so ‐‐
Duff: Yes, but you don't use 'em
for all three things.
Okay.
It's actually
the combination of the tow hook,
two side handles,
and the foot straps
is what our patent
is based off of for the board.
So you have to have
all three things on the board,
and that makes it unique?
‐Right.
‐It's unique process of riding.
‐Somebody else can't do that.
‐Right.
With this board
and this combination,
it is the perfect scenario.
It is the perfect way
to get ‐‐
Then why haven't
you sold more?
Well,
we industry disrupted,
so it's a little hard
for ‐‐
You industry disrupted
four years ago, though.
Blakely: I want to jump in
for a second and help you guys
because I like you guys, okay?
‐Sorry, Sara. Keep going.
So, when you come out
and you present a product,
you should always start
with the problem,
then why the other solutions
are flawed...
Duff: Okay.
...and then what
you're offering
and why it's different.
Is the problem because
a lot of people can't get up,
or are they getting hurt?
I'm a little touchy‐feely,
so when I tell the story,
be prepared.
Okay. Glen, Glen, please give
a direct answer.
We've got
that you're very emotional...
‐No, but the problem ‐‐
‐...you care about this,
you love this ‐‐
Greiner: Yeah. Okay.
She asked for the problem,
I'm gonna tell her the problem.
The problem was we would bring
a bunch of kids out
after church on the water,
and we wanted them
to be successful.
Right.
And they couldn't ride
anything.
Okay. That's good.
I'm getting the problem.
We felt terrible,
so we sat down,
we flipped over our napkins,
started drawing some ideas,
went straight to the garage,
grabbed a piece of wood,
cut it out.
In 10 minutes,
we're on the water.
We failed.
The next day
we did it again.
The third day
we're like, "Whoa."
The people at the marina
that thought we were crazy
are going, "Wow."
Now, fast forward,
we've put this on the boat ‐‐
This is what they want to ride
all the time.
So, Glen,
why haven't you sold more?
Guys, I've never heard
a disrupter call themselves
or their products or their
services "disruptive," right?
Disrupters go and disrupt,
and the market tells them
they're disruptive.
And I think he has been called
a "Disrupter,"
and that's why
he's saying that.
Well, but ‐‐
but the point is it's ‐‐
it's more of the deflection
rather than an answer.
I'm out.
Thank you.
Okay. I can't even see us
having a conversation.
I'm out.
Th‐Thank you,
Daymond.
We appreciate that.
Thank you.
‐All right. But, you guys,
I want to go back
to the product itself.
Sure.
Is there competition?
Parks: So, there have been
knock‐offs.
Um, there was one
in particular
that we believe
seriously violated our claims,
but it's a large brand
who wanted
to seize the opportunity,
so we actually
have found lawyers
on 100% contingency...
That's lucky.
...pursing that litigation
so that we can focus
on the business
'cause, honestly,
we are not interested
in litigating.
I want to go back
to what matters ‐‐ the numbers.
‐Yes.
‐The numbers.
The last number ‐‐
Excuse me, Lori.
This ‐‐ this matters.
All right, and before he goes
to the numbers,
I want to finish
on the patent thing,
'cause I don't want
to beat a dead horse.
Enough with the patent.
If they have no sales,
who gives a ‐‐
No, I have one last question
that matters.
Yes?
So you got
into litigation.
Correct.
Did you win?
Uh, there was
a summary judgment issued.
Uh ‐‐
‐What was the decision?
It was not in our favor.
You don't think
that was relevant?
No, it ‐‐ it was.
I was trying to talk, and ‐‐
‐Right.
‐So, unfortunately,
you have to continue on
with your ‐‐
‐We do, but ‐‐ but ‐‐
‐Fortunately, we'll continue
in front
of three patent judges,
not a local guy
that doesn't know patent law.
I understand
your patent issues.
Yeah.
I understand
the litigation.
I want to ask you
about the numbers.
Okay.
You told me you were gonna do
a million in sales.
Yes, sir.
Okay.
What are you gonna make
on that million this year?
If we had
a‐a million dollars in sales,
we will likely, uh,
net $200,000 in net profit.
20%
without paying yourselves.
Without paying ourselves.
Okay,
do you have any debt?
We do have debt.
Again, uh ‐‐
How much debt
do you have?
$550,000 in debt.
‐Whoa!
‐Ohh.
But collateralized
by inventory.
‐High inventory.
‐We have a lot of inventory.
This year's supposed
to be a windfall.
It really is a turning point
for the business.
How much cash in the bank
do you have?
$100,000 in the bank
right now.
We've got $200,000 in ‐‐
in receivables.
Yeah, over $200,000.
Hey, guys ‐‐ Guys, I got
to tell you something.
If you don't have a good season,
you're going to zero.
You know that?
The story's not pretty.
It's getting a little uglier
the more I ask
about the balance sheet,
okay?
I did two seconds worth
of analysis ‐‐
You have to monetize
your inventory, like, now.
Which is what is
happening right now.
Well, I hope so, but you are
a 50‐50 chance away from zero.
I'm out.
We loved being able
to present to you.
Thank you.
Guys, when I look
to invest ‐‐
It's like a poker game,
right?
I'm either all in
or I fold.
I'm looking at
what you guys have.
There are some problems.
It's really iffy.
If I can't be all in,
I have to fold.
So I'm sorry, I'm out.
Aw.
So, does any other board
have the hook
where the handle goes
on it?
Other boards do have hooks,
but they have recessing hooks,
and part of the system
that makes this so great ‐‐
When that hook recesses,
you have to push down
to get it to pop back up,
which many people don't do.
So, you know what I would've
loved to have seen?
Yes?
'Cause that's a big,
important point of difference ‐‐
probably the biggest
point of difference ‐‐
I wouldn't have spent too
much time on the knee pads.
I would have shown
the other product
and pinched my fingers
in front of us and said...
Right.
..."This is the problem."
Yeah.
You said you have
four daughters.
‐Yeah.
‐That was your biggest concern.
Well, I don't want
to be negative.
‐No.
‐Listen, you have to be willing
to point out the difference
on why you're better.
You're taking
your own sweat equity.
That's not about
being negative.
Okay.
It's not about
going negative.
It's about being factual.
You're asking us
to invest money in you.
I have to feel comfortable.
You shouldn't feel
bad about that.
I think you guys need
a little bit of work
on your marketing message,
starting with why, and that's
gonna be your biggest asset,
but for that reason,
I'm out.
Well said.
Thank you, guys.
Wow.
‐Well ‐‐
‐Hang in, you guys.
‐Expect ‐‐
‐Good luck, you guys.
‐Guys, thank you very much.
‐Expect some orders from me,
'cause I'm ordering
those boards.
Thank you very much.
We appreciate it.
‐They are ‐‐
‐You know what?
Great product,
horrible management.
‐They are dead and walking.
‐Horrible management.
‐That is going to zero.
Hoo!
Wish we'd have gotten
that deal.
Ahh!
Dream came true, though,
getting this far.
A really awesome
opportunity.
You know, the business
has got some challenges,
but we're gonna make
this successful,
and people out on the boat are
gonna love it no matter what.
Mm‐hmm.
♪♪
Narrator: Next into the Tank
is a product
designed to help new moms.
♪♪
Hello, Sharks.
My name is Wendy Colson,
and my company is Boobie Bar,
and I am seeking $150,000
for 10% of my company.
Sharks, Boobie Bar is
the hottest spot in Las Vegas.
Just kidding!
[ Laughter ]
Well, I'm out.
Sorry to disappoint you.
Boobie Bar
is a lactation bar
designed
for breast‐feeding moms,
the most convenient
and yummiest way
to support a healthy
milk supply.
As a lactation consultant,
I have witnessed
the beautiful relationship
between Mom and baby
when breast feeding.
But it's also a stressful time
where moms worry
about their milk supply.
Some moms will turn
to lactation herbs
to increase their
milk production,
but they are stuck ‐‐
stuck swallowing up
to 15 pills a day
or brewing
up to six cups of tea.
Who has time for that
when you just had a baby?
So I combined a proprietary
blend of organic lactation herbs
into one delicious bar
to take on the go
for the busiest people
on the planet ‐‐ moms!
So come on, Sharks,
help me help more moms
reach their lactation goals,
and let's make Boobie
a household name.
[ Laughter ]
I brought you some to taste.
Great.
What happens if men eat it?
[ Chuckles ]
Well, if I could get
a man to lactate...
If ‐‐
if you see a leak...
I would ‐‐ I would already
be sitting in your chairs.
Thank you, Daymond.
O'Leary: Right here.
Thank you.
‐Mr. Wonderful.
‐Thank you.
Cuban: Thank you, Wendy.
Blakely: So, these are three
different flavors?
‐Three different flavors.
‐Okay.
Wendy, what's your
top‐selling flavor?
Colson: Oatmeal chocolate chip.
John: It's good, actually.
‐Thank you!
‐It is good.
Colson: There's a gluten‐free
peanut butter.
Greiner: Ooh, I like
the peanut butter one.
And there's
a blueberry coconut.
The peanut butter
one's gluten‐free?
Yes.
This is good.
If I had knockers,
I'd eat this every day.
How many other lactation
bars are there?
There are no other lactation
bars in the commercial market.
I wanted to give a more
convenient way
for the millennial mom
to take her herbs.
A lot of people ‐‐
I have to ask a question ‐‐
Do you have any proof
that they work,
other than anecdotal
or personal ‐‐
Anecdotal, for sure.
So, Wendy, is the story
for thousands of years,
women have used these herbs
and spices to support lactation?
Right.
That's ‐‐
There's no medical test ‐‐
They help other things,
right.
‐Okay. Yeah.
‐But you don't have ‐‐
To Mark's point, you haven't
done any clinical trials.
Not clinical, but I,
before releasing the product,
I did
my own independent study.
So, I gave a group of moms
that I didn't know
and just asked them
to eat one bar a day,
and then we studied
their milk supply
and we saw in‐‐
increases from 1.5 to 4.6 a day.
Ounces?
Ounces, which is like
an extra feed.
I've used this product
since 2011 with my patients.
I'm a registered nurse,
and I'm also
an internationally
board‐certified
lactation consultant.
I'm an expert
in breast feeding.
There's no higher credentials
for breast‐feeding education.
I might be one of the only
people on the panel ‐‐
I don't know ‐‐
that's breast fed, and ‐‐
‐Mark breast fed.
‐Wait a second.
I breast fed as well.
It was a lot of years ago,
but I was involved.
At Spanx, most of
my employees are women,
and we actually
have lactation rooms.
Mm‐hmm.
And I think
this is interesting.
Cuban:
So, anybody can make a claim,
and anybody can mislead
a mother who needs the help ‐‐
No.
No, no.
I'm not making a claim.
That's what's ‐‐
But you are making claims
because you have a bar
that you say
is going to improve the ability
for a mom to lactate, right?
But the expectation
of the mom
is that she's gonna
get a result,
yet you have no proof
that she's able to get a result
other than your
personal experiences.
‐This is not ‐‐
‐Well, look ‐‐
Blakely: Okay, there's all these
energy bars on the market,
and the herbs and the different
ingredients in the energy bars
are what has been proven
to give energy.
She has ‐‐
Are you serious?
‐Yeah.
‐What do your customers say?
Colson: All right, let me ‐‐
let me first ‐‐
I‐I hear you all,
and I totally get it,
and I want you to know that.
You're probably not in business
to sell one bar to one person,
'cause if it doesn't work,
then you don't have
a business, right?
And I think the bottom line
is the proof is in the pudding,
and as you've been
out selling it
have you been getting
reorders?
Absolutely.
Can you give us
information about that,
because, you know, I have
a 15‐month at home,
and I know the ‐‐
the need for it.
Right.
So just tell us about
how many customers
you had, reorders,
and things of that nature.
Absolutely.
Okay, so right now
on my website,
I have a 52% repeat customer.
Last month was 86%.
Those are
impressive numbers.
How many have you sold
since inception?
My total sales...
So, what year did you start?
...in ‐‐ in 2 years
are $778,000.
‐Whoa!
‐Nice!
That's fantastic.
And I ‐‐
Well ‐‐ Well,
hold on there, cowboy!
Well, wait a minute!
Yippie‐aye‐oh‐ki‐yay.
Now you're speaking
their language, right?
Right.
Okay.
O'Leary: I believe in sales,
so let's just talk about
how many women are lactating
at any one time in the market.
How many in America?
There's about
3.8 million births a year.
81% initiate breast feeding,
which means about
3 million moms.
How do you get to them?
I'm in 500 stores.
What stores?
Buy Buy Baby, Babies"R"Us,
I just got Walmart.
How many stores
are they putting into?
200, because it goes
in a specific section.
‐Yeah, yeah.
‐Got it, got it.
‐And they're testing it.
‐So they're testing 200.
So they started
a woman's section...
‐Yeah.
‐...a one‐stop shop aisle
for a woman
who just had a baby.
Have they told you their target
sell‐through to roll it out?
No, they ‐‐ Um, I just know
I go on shelves in January.
First of all, there's a huge
need for lactation expertise,
so I'm not trying
to denigrate the need.
But that said, what concerns me
is you're making money,
and if you really do get
confirmation through a study,
you could be the one
that solves the problem.
That should be
the first thing...
Mm‐hmm.
...'cause then every doctor's
gonna recommend it.
Every box can say
"Clinically proven
to solve your problem
in these circumstances."
Mm‐hmm.
The fact that you don't,
to me,
is just one more curse of
the supplement business, right,
'cause everybody
makes lots of claims
and people who are desperate
spend their money.
I'm out.
Thank you.
I'm sorry to hear that.
Because you don't have the
clinical testing at this time,
I can't put my name
behind it,
and for that reason,
I'm out.
Wendy, I'm struggling
because I love the mission
behind what you're doing.
Where I'm getting caught up
is on the proven results.
Like, that matters so deeply
to me for the consumer.
The moms come back ‐‐
they buy.
I know,
and I'm so proud of you,
and I'm happy that
you have happy customers,
but it's for
that reason that I ‐‐
I need to be out.
Thank you, Sara.
You guys, I have something
called Club Boobie Bar.
You sign up, and you get
five boxes, 30‐day supply, $79.
I've had women on
Club Boobie Bar for over a year,
so I know there's no,
like, clinical proof,
but why would they buy...
‐Wendy, good news.
...over and over ‐‐
A third of my wine buyers
are in my wine club.
They get a case
every 90 days.
I have a massive
fulfillment facility doing this.
I love this business.
Mm‐hmm.
Your proof is sales.
In sales, I trust.
I will give you
$150,000 for 20%.
I think
a lot of work ahead ‐‐
You have no idea
what Walmart's gonna be like.
I do.
That's an extraordinary
opportunity.
Good on you
for getting it,
but get ready
for some serious work,
and serious
full‐time employees.
And legal work, too.
Thank you for your offer.
Is there anyone else
that has anything?
John: I think
you're the real deal.
I don't necessarily agree
with my fellow Sharks,
on if it could be
credible or not
'cause I just really believe
that you either see
it's working,
or you don't, right?
Right.
And I ‐‐ And that's it.
Uh, but I think
you're the star,
and I think your information
has to get out there.
I don't want you to be stuck
manufacturing and warehousing.
My intent is to take you,
and we license this thing,
and you are the face,
so $150,000 and 20%.
Thank you so much
for your offer.
Okay, Wendy, you have
two offers ‐‐
both $150,000 for 20%.
What are you going to do?
They're both amazing offers.
That's what makes
this so difficult.
I... [ Sighs ]
But you have to make
a decision.
I know, I know.
Do you go with the guy
who's currently going through
the same situation
that those mothers
will be going through,
or do you go with somebody who
is going through male menopause?
You have to make
a decision.
‐You know what?
‐And welcome to the Shark Tank.
Daymond, you have
a very good point.
You are in the trenches
with what ‐‐
exactly what this product is.
Daymond, I accept your offer.
Yeah!
[ Laughter, applause ]
All right.
That last stab ‐‐
I got him.
Thank you, thank you ‐‐
Congratulations.
Thank you.
John: I love it.
‐You're in the Boob business!
‐Boobie Bar.
Of course you love it.
Yeah!
Colson:
I mean, that was so hard.
I am just so excited,
because I‐I couldn't ask
for a better Shark.
♪♪
Narrator: Next into the tank
is a business
started by a viral hit.
♪♪
Hi, Sharks.
My name is Eugenia,
and I'm from
San Clemente, California.
I have to apologize ‐‐
My business partner
isn't here yet.
He couldn't keep track of time
if his life depended on it ‐‐
can't even get himself dressed
in the morning sometimes.
Huxley?
Huxley, come on!
Come on, buddy.
[ Laughter ]
‐Come on! Good boy!
‐Aww!
‐[ Laughs ]
‐What?
What is that?
All right.
[ Laughter ]
Don't be afraid ‐‐
This panda is domesticated.
I'm Eugenia, and this is
Huxley the Panda Puppy.
We're here seeking $60,000 for
20% of our company, Pandaloon.
Our Panda Puppy costume
transforms your pet
into the perfect
walking teddy bear.
Now your dog doesn't have
to be just a dog ‐‐
He can be a turducken of cute.
Have a look.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
Oh, m‐‐
Aww, the poor dog!
[ Laughter ]
Oh, my goodness.
O'Leary: That is sick.
‐Aah...
‐That is so sick.
Not only does the
Panda Puppy costume epitomize
the magical cuteness
of a walking teddy bear,
but it's also engineered
for the perfect fit.
Your pet wears the costume
like a hoodie
with the front legs
through the lower bear legs.
And unlike those cheap
Velcro costumes,
the back adjusts...
[ Laughter ]
...to your pet's neck
and chest girth.
That dog's gonna
have issues, though.
[ Laughter ]
All right...
People are going crazy
for this little panda.
He's received more views than
Beyoncé's last music video.
How many views?
Over 140 million.
Wow.
John: Get out of here.
It actually went viral
by accident. [ Chuckles ]
I had a store
in the theme of pandas,
and, um, made a video
just for fun on Halloween,
and it just went nuts.
So we started with pandas,
and now we have
the Panda Puppy Friends.
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
I also brought samples
for each of you.
Would you mind, uh,
holding Huxley for a second?
‐I'll hold the puppy!
‐Okay.
‐Aww!
Cuban: Someone gets
to hold the panda.
He's ‐‐ Ooh!
And you can take him
out if you like.
Hi!
‐Mr. Wonderful.
‐Thank you very much.
Blakely: Thank you.
♪♪
Eugenia,
this is good quality.
Thank you.
Yeah.
Is it possible to put Huxley
in this one?
Sure. Yeah.
[ Chuckles ]
So, do you need a small
rat‐size dog,
or can you have
a larger dog?
[ Laughs ]
They can be sized
to fit larger dogs.
That's part of what I tried
to make sure I designed it for,
was to fit a variety
of dog shapes.
Eugenia,
what's your background?
Well, I'm from San Clemente,
California, a little beach town.
My parents immigrated
here from Taiwan.
So I went on,
did well in school,
I got my masters
in computational science,
my bachelor's in math
and applied science.
I, um, was pursuing research
in computational neuroscience
at the Salk Institute
where I used genetic algorithms
to optimize a neural network.
I also teach math.
And you do this.
So, I graduated during the
height of the recession.
Since I graduated, I have
been stringing together
three, four,
five part‐time jobs,
and so that's what really
drove me to start this business.
Have you sold any
or taken preorders, or ‐‐
Yes. I'm actually in the middle
of the manufacturing process.
They'll be ready
in about one month.
What are your costs?
It's about $4 landed
depending on the size.
And then
what do you charge?
What's the retail?
I've been, uh, p‐proposing the
retail price at $39.99, but ‐‐
Whoa.
Daymond, I researched
the largest c‐‐
costume manufacturer
in the world,
and they actually have costumes
that are animal‐themed as well,
and their price point
was about the same, actually,
for a far less
quality of product, so ‐‐
I think that's
a perfect price.
All right. Well, I created
two sizes so far.
‐Aww!
Aww, not quite as good
as the panda, but still good.
So right now you're taking
preorders, correct?
Yes, just very quietly.
And how did you do that,
though?
Pandaloon
is my online store.
We've been in business
for about three years.
Um, we do about $100,000
in revenue every year.
‐What do you sell?
‐We sell just apparel, gifts.
A lot of things with pandas ‐‐
some things without.
Blakely:
So, Eugenia, would be buying
a portion of Pandaloon,
which you currently
already have
or this new concept
of the costume?
I went ahead and bundled it all
together, because I know that ‐‐
Obviously, I don't have,
you know,
an impressive sales figure
to show you of these costumes,
but I do have proof
that I can sell $300,000
worth of inventory over
the lifetime of my business,
I've been profitable
since my very first year.
I've done it all myself.
Okay. What exactly do you
need the money for?
In order to go ahead and expand
my costume into a line,
I would need to have
the inventory
ready for this Halloween.
So in order to do that,
I would need an investment
of a bare minimum of $60,000
to get most of these SKUs
to meet their minimum
order quantity.
So, Eugenia,
I'm fascinated.
It's a heck of a story, and
obviously I‐I found the outfit,
to say the least,
intriguing.
But I have to be
honest with you ‐‐
I've never really
understood people
that dress up rat dogs
in outfits.
It's just bizarre.
I'm not suggesting you are.
I'm just saying I'm out.
Okay.
I think you're phenomenal.
I was more interested in the
neural network side of it.
I figured.
[ Laughter ]
But seriously, I think
you'll do great.
It's just not a fit for me,
so for that reason, I'm out.
Greiner:
And, Eugenia, I'm sorry,
I just don't see
a huge market for this.
I'm out.
Eugenia, I think the fact
that we all
almost curled over
laughing ‐‐
I think bringing
that joy is ‐‐ is evident.
I have an offer for you.
I'll give you the $60,000
for 35%,
and I'm gonna donate 10%
of my 35%
to animal charities.
So, Eugenia, I'm gonna
make you an offer.
I like this, and I like you.
Narrator: Three Sharks are out.
Eugenia has an offer
on the table from Daymond
for her pet costume business,
Pandaloon.
But Sara is also interested.
Eugenia, I'm gonna
make you an offer.
I like this,
and I like you.
Oh, you're kidding.
I'm not kidding.
Okay.
I'm gonna match
Daymond's offer.
I'm gonna give you
$60,000 for 35%.
I have more than I can bring
to the table with my platform
and all of the women
that I'm reaching out to,
and I think that
most of the people
that are gonna buy costumes
for their dogs are women.
I think you're special.
I can tell that you're gonna
make this work, so...
Thank you so much.
Yeah.
I really appreciate that.
So, you have
two great Sharks,
two great offers
on the table.
Would you ever entertain
a deal together?
Are you willing to give
away more equity?
Yeah, yeah.
I'd be open to that.
I'll be very honest.
I ‐‐ I‐I have respect
for Sara.
I don't know her history here.
She probably can add
a massive amount of value,
but I think I'm gonna
ride with this alone.
I'm gonna stick
with my offer.
Eugenia, you got
to make a decision.
♪♪
Daymond, I know that you
are an awesome person
to work with in
the pet market...
so I would love
to accept your offer.
All right!
‐Man, you made me beg for that.
‐Thanks for asking, Eugenia.
I'd love to wear
the panda outfit.
Thank you.
Not at all.
Thank you so much.
‐So crazy.
‐Congrats.
‐Congratulations!
‐Congratulations.
‐Good job.
Chen: It was more equity than
I initially planned on
coming in with,
but, you know, I know
what kind of value
that Daymond
brings to the table.
Um, it's incredible,
and I love that
we're going to
support rescues, too.
You know, I think I'm coming
down with something,
'cause I just dreamt
that you gave $60,000
for a rat‐dog outfit.
[ Laughter ]